[Music]
on this sunday night
electing a leader the conservative party
leadership race
ends tonight the next leader is going to
have a lot of work cut out for them who
will they choose
and what are their chances of becoming
the next prime minister
fire and water wildfires consume
california
as the gulf coast braces for a double
dose of hurricanes
plus a shocking catch i
seen you know some weird looking face
one thing another but
this one took okay hear from the
newfoundland fisherman who netted this
curious creature from the deep
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us we are watching
developing news in ottawa right now as
the votes are counted in the
conservative
leadership race four candidates vying to
replace
andrew scheer as party leader nearly 175
000 votes were cast by mail a record
number of ballots in
any leadership race they were locked up
in this vault until early this morning
when the counting began
now a technical problem with a machine
used to open those envelopes has now
delayed the start of the event but a
party spokesperson says
the program will begin very shortly and
the victor will be revealed later
tonight
and he or she will have their work cut
out uniting the party navigating the
role of opposition leader
and deciding whether to push for an
election once the government resumes in
september
following parliament's propagation
abigail beeman is in ottawa for us
tonight near
the convention center where the leader
will be announced this evening
and abigail i mentioned that technical
delay how are things looking there now
well jeff it's really the definition of
a developing story here with things
continuing to change but the latest from
the party is that the show should start
at any minute now that doesn't mean
we'll get the results anytime soon
they're saying it could be up to an hour
and a half from now before those first
results come in and i'll
explain a bit more about what was the
problem here
the machine is supposed to first cut
open
the envelope but it was cutting into
some of the ballots now there was a
record breaking close to 175 thousand
ballots cast at this point we're told
several thousand of those ballots were
impacted the last information we got was
that there is an issue with three
percent but that 97 percent of the
ballots are in
and have been counted properly so still
waiting for an update to see
when those results will come in of
course
we don't know who will win the top job
and because it's a ranked ballot system
that
could be a while before we have that
information what we do know
is that the person to take on the top
job in the conservative party has their
work cut out for them
have a look the next leader has a month
before the house resumes and it will be
busy
picking out your shadow ministers
putting a team together for your office
coming up with policy
learning how to campaign in a new type
of post-covet environment
kate harrison says job number one will
be securing caucus unity the race
saw a big divide in endorsements from
sitting mps
making sure that all of caucus is united
around
their vision making sure that everybody
feels they have a place and
can have a say in the the new
administration
and really making sure that all of the
sites are now turned towards the liberal
party rather than
inward an election could happen sooner
rather than later so how does the next
conservative leader convince canadians
broadly
they're ready to do what andrew scheer
could not and become
prime minister communicating
continuously
with the canadians that we've made
contact with about the importance of
getting a conservative vision to them in
terms of how to deal with this recovery
from the pandemic
former cabinet minister lisa rate
co-chaired the race's organizing
committee she points to the strong
interest in the party with
record-breaking voter turnout despite
the pandemic
well one thing i'm very proud of is that
in the province of quebec
we tripled our membership and that was
not necessarily a place where we had a
lot of conservative memberships in the
past
quebec will be important as the party
looks to broaden support
outside their historically strong
western presence
it's fantastic that we can sweep seats
out here but that doesn't help us
win government if we can't win in
ontario
and the next leader is going to have a
lot of work cut out for them in growing
our base
growing their base to attract more
suburban urban and diverse voters
convincing more canadians there's a
place for them under the conservative
tent
so the show has just gotten underway
here in ottawa we will still be some
time and we don't know exactly when the
results will
start to come in but a little more on
that ranked ballot system
and how it works in order to win a
candidate needs a majority which is 16
901 points and people voting
can rank up to all four candidates if
they wish in order of their preference
and so if no one wins on that first
ballot
that's when you move to the second and
third ballots and that's why people's
second and third choices can become
so important jeff shaping up to be a
long night thanks abigail
and for more on what to expect now let's
check in with our chief political
correspondent david aiken who joins us
now from ottawa
so david what are you watching for
tonight well jeff we know that there has
been this huge turnout in this race a
whopping 175
000 conservatives voted in this contest
and
that's an all-time record for any
leadership race in the country but
the base is engaged but i'll be looking
for the regional breakdown
are all the votes just from alberta and
saskatchewan or did the party get
quebec voters as well we heard lisa ray
tell abigail that the quebec membership
tripled great
but we're in quebec so those regional
voter turnout numbers are going to tell
us
whether the current conservative party
is truly a national party
or whether it's really now just a party
of the west
interesting question and whatever the
result tonight to what extent do you
think this leadership race will be
a turning point for the conservative
party moving forward
well this is definitely one of those
turning point events for the party no
question if only because
it does represent an eastward shift in
the party's power structure remember
the conservative federal leaders for the
last 20 years
they've all been from the west preston
manning stockwell day
stephen harper andrew scheer even the
interim leader before sheer rona ambrose
she was from edmonton and that put
issues important to western canada right
at the center of power
within the conservative party but no
matter who wins tonight
the leader is going to be from ontario
and i know peter mckay calls himself a
nova scotian but
he has been living in toronto now for
the last five years so
the leadership for the conservative
party is shifting east today now i think
the significance of that shift
is that it's going to shape the new
leaders first weeks and perhaps first
months in office
the west particularly alberta and
saskatchewan is already restless already
unhappy with ottawa
and some in the west are unhappy with
the prospects of a conservative party
that has a leader from the east
so much so they might fall to the lakes
of former harper era minister jay hill
into some form of western separatist
party
but a conservative party that is more
focused on central
canada on ontario and quebec is also a
party
that has greater potential for success
at the ballot box
they've already got just about every
seat you can get between winnipeg and
suburban vancouver
they now need seats around toronto
around montreal so
a conservative party that puts more
emphasis on central canada
that's a party that has a better chance
of beating
justin trudeau and the liberals jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
and as conservatives prepare to name a
new leader tonight also marks the end of
an era for the party under andrew scheer
the conservatives grew their seat count
and won the popular vote in last fall's
election but
ultimately failed to defeat justin
trudeau's liberals well tonight eric
sorenson looks back at shear's
surprising rise to the tory's top job
and his legacy as leader
andrew scheer it was a stunning outcome
for a relatively unknown politician from
saskatchewan
suddenly next in line to be prime
minister of canada what a race this
has been it kept a startling rise in
politics for andrew scheer
first as one of the youngest mps in
parliament homosexual unions are by
nature contradictory to this
shear's opposition to same-sex marriage
made him popular among social
conservatives
his even-handed good nature saw him don
the robes as the youngest
speaker of the house in canadian history
the trustee of giving me to be your
speaker in the 41st department
it's been a great honor then after the
departure of stephen harper
shear shocked his own party and upset
the favorite quebecer maxim bernier
to become at age 38 the youngest
conservative leader in almost
40 years this win is because of your
work
your efforts the pressure was on
immediately to expand the party beyond
his pardoned supporters
the common ground between the different
kinds of conservatives so i'm not going
to
you know put myself in a binary box that
you might want me to
be in shear's soft-spoken style took on
a harder edge to confront justin trudeau
and the liberals
we now know that those were all lies you
have failed
to tell the truth he fired up the
party's social conservative base
especially in the prairies but could not
overcome the liberal's traditional
strength in ontario quebec and atlantic
canada
coming close but falling just short a
politician few expected to lead his
party
could not in the end lead his party to
victory he's the
was the accidental leader i think andrew
scheer was the backup quarterback who
got brought into the the game
and he just didn't know how to complete
passes any chance for shear to get a
second crack at the liberals was
scuttled
after reports surfaced that the
conservative party paid for private
school for his children
i will be resigning as the leader of the
conservative party
of canada shear's departure marks the
end of a quarter century of
western-based leadership
for the conservatives in this country
starting with preston manning then
stockwell day
stephen harper and then shear all
westerners who reflected the party's
growing power base
far from central canada the challenge
for that new leader
not having that western connection will
be to
keep the west welded in so end of an era
absolutely
andrew scheer's leadership left the
conservative party well funded and with
a strong foundation of more than 120
seats in parliament
he won't get a second opportunity to
take on the trudeau liberals
but he left his party in good shape to
do so next time
eric sorensen global news toronto and to
politics
south of the border now where the
republican national convention is set to
start
tomorrow and protesters are already
gathering near the site
president donald trump and vice
president mike pence are expected to be
officially nominated onto the gop
ticket but trump's character is once
again being called into question
after secret recordings of his sister
were made public
jennifer johnson explains protesters
have taken to the streets of charlotte
north carolina
ahead of the start of the republican
national convention despite the covet 19
pandemic
u.s president donald trump is expected
to thank delegates in person
at the convention center monday we're
going to talk about the american story
about all the accomplishments that we've
had over the last four years with
president trump and what the president's
second term vision is going to look like
the gop's big event to formally nominate
the trump
pence ticket comes as the president's
sister is making headlines
the washington post first reported that
marianne trump barry
a retired federal judge was secretly
recorded by the president's niece
on those recordings barry is heard
saying her brother has no principles
and can't be trusted the change of story
is a lack of preparation the lying the
holy
but he's appealing to the base trump
berry has not commented on the
recordings but the white house chief of
staff is defending the president
this is politics as usual by by
a niece that was written out of a will
that
would apparently just has an axe to
grime
meanwhile the president is facing a new
battle with congress
in a rare weekend session the house
approved a bill giving the u.s postal
service
25 billion dollars and banned the
removal of mail collection boxes and
sorting machines
ahead of november's election postmaster
general lewis de joy a major trump
campaign donor
had ordered the removal of the equipment
then warned 46 states
some votes for the election may not be
counted in time we will send it to the
senate
and let me just say that as i've always
said public sentiment is everything
they'll be hearing
from their constituents because this
hits
home senate republicans say they have no
plans to act on the legislation
and president trump has already
threatened to veto it
jennifer johnson global news washington
to the kovit 19 pandemic now and cases
are surging
in manitoba that province just recorded
its largest daily spike since the start
of the pandemic
and its chief public health officer says
the number should act as a wake-up call
manitoba just recorded 72 new cases
in just 24 hours that brings the
province's total number of cases to 944.
investigators in iran say they've now
recovered about 19
seconds of cockpit conversation from
that ukrainian jetliner that was shot
down over tehran back in january
data from the black boxes reveals it was
hit by two missiles
25 seconds apart and that passengers
were still alive for some time after the
first impact
the flight recorders were sent to paris
in june to be examined by a team of
international investigators
including experts from canada all 176
people on board
died in that crash including 55
canadians
still ahead a deadly stampede after
police in peru
break up in a legal pandemic party
thousands gathered in the capital of
belarus again today
demanding the country's longtime ruler
quit
protests have been sweeping that country
since elections two weeks ago handed
alexander lukashenko
a landslide victory and a sixth term in
office
the opposition claims that vote was
rigged
and to a deadly stampede in peru after
police raided a crowded disco to enforce
a covid 19 lockdown
13 people were crushed to death when
officers shut down the dance party at
this nightclub in lima
peru closed all bars and nightclubs back
in march due to the pandemic
when police arrived more than a hundred
patrons made a run for it
through the only door on the building's
second floor trampling each other as
they tried to escape
and music fans in germany crammed
together for an indoor concert
but instead of breaking the rules they
were taking part in a scientific
experiment more than 4 000 volunteers
attended the concert
set up by researchers studying how the
virus spreads at large gatherings
fans were given face masks and
fluorescent hand gel to identify
frequently touched surfaces
and they also wore electronic trackers
that determine the contact
rates and distances of individuals at
these events
still ahead vanishing glaciers how
global warming is hitting alberta's
drinking water
you're watching global national
[Music]
a calmer night in northern california
allowed firefighters to make some
progress against a trio of massive fires
but crews are now bracing for a weather
system that's expected to bring more
high winds and lightning storms flames
have already destroyed nearly one
thousand homes and other structures
and tens of thousands have been forced
to leave the fires burning on all sides
of the san francisco bay area
were started by lightning strikes over
the past week
and hurricane warnings have now been
declared along the u.s gulf coast
as thousands brace for back to back
blows from
two powerful storms tropical storm marco
powered into a category 1 hurricane
today
and laura is also picking up steam in
the caribbean as both track towards the
u.s
hurricane marco is forecast to slam into
texas and southeastern louisiana
tomorrow
while laura is likely to strengthen into
a hurricane and hit late wednesday
or early thursday we've heard the
warnings of how climate change is
melting glaciers in the arctic but a new
report warns the impact is being felt
much closer to home
alberta's rivers are a key source of
drinking water for the province
and as glaciers shrink so does the water
supply
a new study has identified the
communities most at risk
and jordan armstrong reports it includes
one of the country's most
popular tourist destinations lake louise
is world
famous for its mountains and emerald
waters
but when it comes to the drinking water
the community could be in for a future
of supply problems
that's according to a geophysics phd
candidate
who spent three years studying alberta's
vanishing glaciers
what the tourists will be seeing when
they look at those mountains
is mountains that have less snow less
ice cover
um and then when they're looking at the
river they'll see that in august it will
be lower on average
the town of lake louise gets its water
from the glacier-fed bow river
with less runoff in august anderson says
the drinking supply becomes
inconsistent his study found hinton
rocky mountain house and the bighorn dam
face the same problem the dam's
reservoir is a water source for more
than one million albertans
including edmonton um and so that's why
there are so many people who are
you know concerned about these findings
anderson says current models project
western canada will lose more than 70
percent of its remaining glacier ice
volume
in the next 80 years his study a first
of its kind to pinpoint
the alberta communities most at risk
from the big melt of climate change
we can now focus our efforts in trying
to figure out
what are the what's the specific timings
of change that
those locations are going to see and
what are the effective policies that we
can use to help manage the water there
as the glaciers shrink it's not just
photo opportunities
that begin to dry up jordan armstrong
global news
vancouver up next
a curious catch that left a canadian
fisherman
flummoxed
jersey jersey jersey
we'll talk about an underdog story
jersey an
11-pound jack russell terrier wasn't
afraid to take on this large
black bear in bc when his owners
accidentally stumbled upon it at a farm
without hesitation the dog ran towards
the bear barking right at its face
now luckily the bear smartened up and
went on its way while jersey walked back
with his tail wagging and his head high
good dog
even for the most experienced sailors
the ocean can be full of surprises and
that was certainly the case
last week during a fishing trip in
newfoundland and labrador
as ross lord reports the fishermen
netted something so strange
even the oldest hands on board were
mystified
for many people in atlanta canada
fishing is a way of life
fish harvesters encounter everything
from hard shelled lobsters
to soft and mushy jellyfish to the
mighty great
white shark but every now and then they
make a truly
rare catch and go by
brought up solid what in the name of god
is that we got there
what it was almost defies description a
one meter long creature from the ocean
depths
with an appearance unlike anything
they'd ever seen
so we brought it into uh valley field
and we brought it into the port and the
fish plant
and there's people there i mean lots of
people and lots of fishermen
and nobody ever seen nothing close like
it
after asking around on social media
goodyear finally got an
answer the long-nosed chimera a rarely
seen fish that lives as far down as 2600
meters below surface
by the time it landed on the boat it had
died likely from a change in water
pressure
marine researchers say the chimera is
made entirely of cartilage
with feathery fins that resemble a
bird's wings
and a sharp spine that's dangerous to
predators
researchers have no idea how many
chimeras lurk in the deeps
because so few are caught which could
make this one
a fish story for the ages it's like
winning the lotto i guess
you never know what you're going to get
ross lord
global news and that is global national
for this sunday i'm jeff semple
tonight's your canada
is the regatta in lunenburg nova scotia
it's the largest kilboad event of the
summer sailing season in the province
now many other regattas were canceled
this year because of the kovit 19
pandemic of course
but recently eased restrictions in nova
scotia allowed these races to go ahead
this weekend
thanks for watching robin gill will be
back here with you tomorrow have a great
[Music]
night